ce premier bilan des talibans un mois
après alors reconquête du pays on en
parle tout de suite avec régis le
sommier grand reporter rt france bonjour
un régis merci d'être avec nous vous
connaissez bien l'afghanistan on va le
répéter vous avez séjourné plusieurs
semaines cet été avant la prise de
kaboul après un mois est ce qu'on peut
dire finalement que les talibans ils
contrôlent définitivement un afghanistan
alors ça c'est tout le problème c'est le
prochain problème afghan qui contrôlent
l'afghanistan et qui a déjà contrôler
l'afghanistan s'avèrent l'afghanistan
est un pays de deux vallées c'est un
pays de 2 2 route de montagne c'est un
pays passage donc beaucoup de conquérant
travers l'histoire ont essayé de
conquérir l'afghanistan beaucoup l'ont
traversée mais très peu ils sont restés
en a surnommé l afghanistan le cimetière
des empires et la dernière mésaventure
américaine le prouve encore une fois
c'est très difficile de contrôler
l'afghanistan et ça le sera aussi pour
les talibans qui tente justement de
contrôler le pays d'asseoir leur pouvoir
on sait qu'ils ont lancé une offensive
plus ou moins réussis sur le le
pandjchir donc la dernière zone qui leur
échappait ils ont appris à rieux conquis
cette cette zone très montagneuse mais
rien n'est sûr les zones de l'est de
l'afghanistan sont toujours des zones
quasiment incontrôlable avec des
influences et des infiltrations venant
du pakistan en particulier donc les
talibans aujourd'hui doivent prouver
qu'ils sont capables de maîtriser qui
sont capables de se coordonner on le
moment le secrétaire de d2 de l'union
européenne disait qu' ils sont ils des
rivalités entre eux c'est une réalité il
ya eu notamment une rivalité entre le
négociateur le mollah baradar qui
étaient en dehors et sirajuddin haqqani
qui fait partie du réseau haqqani qui
sont des durs chez les talibans des
militaires et qui chacun aujourd'hui se
partagent le pouvoir donc il ya sept
cette rivale ces rivalités entre eux et
puis les talibans doivent aujourd'hui
prouver que c'est bien d'avoir combattu
les américains c'est bien d'avoir gagné
militairement mes administrés ou comment
contrôler est capable d'approvisionner
un pays le faire tenir économiquement
financièrement un tiers des afghans pour
le répéter sont aujourd'hui n'arrive pas
à se nourrir donc est-ce que les
talibans vont être capables de relever
ce défi toute la question est là et
l'aide internationale est un peu
conditionné va y avoir une sorte de
monnaie d'échangé on a vu le droit des
femmes d'un côté la capacité aussi à
fournir c'est comment cette nourriture
de la communauté internationale tout ça
va être l'objet de tractations et
négociations entre les talibans et le
reste du monde à vous parler du panchir
ya donc un chef de la résistance locale
ahmad masood cas le fils du commandant
massoud assassiné en 2001 il appelle
donc à chaque afghan à se soulever est
ce qu'il a réellement les moyens de ses
ambitions
alors non évidemment il est réfugié donc
avec l'ancien vice président sales est
également d'algues à nice temps dans ces
montagnes du pandjchir les montagnes du
panjshir faut savoir c'est un c'est une
zone qui à l'époque d'une union
soviétique a été assez lugubre l'objet
de quatre offensive n'a par des troupes
russes qui sont qui ont pénétré dans la
vallée mais qui n'ont jamais réussi à la
contrôler complètement à l'époque de
l'ancien gouvernement taliban entre 96
et 2001 également le panchir a été
l'objet de convoitises mais n'est jamais
tombé complètement là cette fois ci ils
ont été vaincus mais ils se sont
réfugiés dans les montagnes et là c'est
extrêmement difficile de les déloger
parce que ce sont des montagnards c'est
leur mode de vie et puis le panchir
culmine à près de 5600 mètres d'altitude
on est sur les contreforts de l'himalaya
on est dans l'hindu kuch fort vous
réalisez le type de géographie que ce
que et les l'afghanistan est une leçon
de géographie justement pour pouvoir le
contrôler il faut vraiment être capable
de contrôler ces endroits là qui sont
quasiment inaccessibles donc le le
problème va être pour cette résistance
pour cette
de savoir si elle peut s'appliquer au
reste du pays est-ce que du pandjchir
peut partir une résistance qui viendrait
à conquérir kaboul on est le panchir est
seulement à 80 km de kaboul mais est-ce
qu'ils ont des relais est ce que dans
les milieux éclairés de la capitale
parce que bon
faut quand même reconnaître que depuis
vingt ans la capitale afghane a été a
vécu au diapason du reste du monde il ya
un certain nombre de gens qui sont allés
à l'école de femmes qui sont allées à
l'école et des érudits et qu'ils ne sont
pas prêts à se soumettre justement
comment aux joutes à liban et est donc
est ce que cette résistance là et la
résistance du pain de gier peuvent de la
peut émerger quelque chose qui prennent
la place des talibans ou en tout cas qui
les renverse rien n'est sûr c'est encore
trop tôt pour le dire mais du paon dire
en tant que tel seul je ne crois pas que
la résistance du pandjchir puisse un
jour reconquérir l'afghanistan en tout
cas on a aussi le sentiment qu'on
focalise beaucoup en tout cas les médias
et les pouvoirs occidentaux sur le fils
du commandant massoud
comme si on voulait en faire finalement
une icône du combat pour la liberté
comme ce fut le cas pour son père qui
pourtant auraient été responsables quand
même d'un certain nombre de violations
de droits humains lorsqu'ils
contrôlaient notamment la capitale
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais
écoutez ahmad shah massoud donc le père
de ahmad masood évidemment était un
seigneur de guerre afghans mise à part
si on si on commet si on se détache un
petit peu de l'image du perrier
romantique qu'il a su vendre en occident
cette image et qu'il a su vendre aussi
un certain nombre d'afghans il faut
reconnaître quand même qu'il a qui
dispose d'une popularité même au delà de
l'ethnie tadjik à laquelle il appartient
ahmad shah massoud était un seigneur de
guerre qui a eu des alliances avec
d'autres seigneurs de guerre gulbuddin
hekmatyar
abdul rashid dostum où ils se sont fait
la guerre parfois ils ont fait des
allées en c1 avec les autres à une
époque oui les troupes de massoud ont
détruit kaboul
massoud également un certain nombre de
gares et de matsu de massoud ont
massacré des hasards qui est punu une
ethnie chiites comme modéré donc voila
tout ces jeux d'alliances pendant la
guerre civile ou de mes alliances ont
amené la ruine du pays et à cause de ces
seigneurs de guerre dont massoud faisait
partie les talibans sont arrivés au
pouvoir parce que les talibans ont su
appelé à l'unité nationale et mettre un
terme justement à ces seigneurs de
guerre qui pillent littéralement le pays
donc le l'héritage de massoud il est
mitigé il est effectivement extrêmement
populaire internationalement populaire
en afghanistan dans certains secteurs
d'un pianiste ans mais évidemment pas
partout vous allez chez les hasards à
vous avez chéri pachtoune personne ne
parle de massoud donc la question de la
figure romantique la figure de chef
d'état du commandant massoud elle est
tout à fait contestable d'un point de
vue afghans on a entendu tout à l'heure
le chef de la diplomatie américain
anthony blinken rendre des comptes parce
que ce bilan de reconquête du pouvoir
les talibans c'est aussi le bilan du
retrait américain depuis un mois
on sait que la communauté internationale
est là un levier c'est l'aide financière
finalement est-ce que ça c'est une
pression pour la communauté
internationale sur les talibans je pense
que oui en effet une partie du d'éclat
des déclarations du porte parole des
talibans ce matin souligné justement ce
désir de co2 coopérer se disait
justement de recevoir cette aide
financière parce que les talibans savent
qu'ils en ont besoin maintenant jusqu'où
sont ils prêts à faire des concessions
par rapport à ce que ce qu'a dit anthony
blinken est ce que et la façon dont la
communauté internationale perçoit les
talibans il faut quand même reconnaître
une chose c'est que ça fait un mois
qu'ils sont au pouvoir en un mois qu'est
ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont d'abord voilà
ils n'ont pas commis des exactions comme
il l'avait fait en prenant le pouvoir en
96 en tout cas pas dans cette proportion
à dire on n'a pas vu de pendaisons
publiques on n'a pas vu de lapidation on
n'a pas vu de femme exécutée dans les
stades comme on avait pu le voir à
l'époque néanmoins qu est-ce qui ont-ils
nommé à leur tête à leur tête ils ont un
mollah qui s'appelle ah koon zada dont
le fils est mort en kamikaze dans un
attentat suicide en 2007 donc ça c'est
le chef ensuite parmi les ministres vous
avez le fils du mollah omar est quand
même yacoub le mollah yakup fils du
mollah omar direct héritiers de celui
qui a accueilli ben laden vous avez
également si j'arrête
sirajuddin haqqani qui est le donc le
chef de ce qu'on appelle le réseau
haqqani qui était recherché par les
américains il y avait sur sa tête 10
millions de dollars parce qu'il avait
directement été impliqué dans l'attentât
de l'hôtel intercontinental en 2017 un
attentat qui se levait pas plus de 100
morts
donc voyez le genre de personne qu'ils
ont mis au pouvoir est ce que les
américains espéraient c'est qu'il y ait
une petite ouverture voir la communauté
internationale il peut être une femme ça
ne s'est pas produit il n'y a pas et
figures d'opposition qui ont été nommés
dans ce gouvernement c'est un
gouvernement intra talibans qui
représente d'ailleurs des factions
souvent rivales ont l'art on l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure mais ce n'est
certainement pas un gouvernement
d'ouverture ni un gouvernement inclusif
comme le souhaitait jean yves le drian
ou d'autres personnes comme l'avait
appelé de leurs voeux aussi les
américains donc finalement il n'y a pas
eu de concession pour la côte sur la
communauté internationale les talibans
n'ont simplement autorisé les femmes sur
la question féminine à reprendre les
cours à la faculté nous on l'a vu il
femmes sont couvertes de deux noirs sont
séparés elles doivent sortir cinq
minutes avant il ya des codes très
précis voilà tout ça c'est pour le
moment une mascarade il n'y a absolument
pas de concessions qui ont été faits et
pour le moment s'il l'aide
internationale doit être corrélé à ça il
faut que la communauté internationale
reste ferme vis-à-vis de en disant voilà
si vous franchissez cette ligne ou si
vous ne faites pas c'est qu'on sait sur
la vous n'aurez pas dead ils étaient dix
dont savent très bien qu'ils ne peuvent
pas aujourd'hui sans argent dans la
communauté internationale maintenir le
pays telle qu'ils l'ont ce qui risque de
se passer parce que vous savez les
halles les habitants sont très
versatiles
pinilla des jeux d'alliances ont il ya
un vieux proverbe afghans qui dit on ne
peut jamais on ne jamais acheter un
afghan mais on peut le louer et bien et
c'est toujours ce jeu de deux
changements de 2,2 changement d'alliance
etc les talibans aujourd'hui ont le vent
en poupe ils ont eu l'ascendant sur
l'armée afghane ils ont réussi à la
démobilisés plus qu'à la vaincre l afs
et ses combats plus qu'elle n'a combattu
contre eux donc ils sont arrivés au
pouvoir apparaît qu'à peu près 75 mille
combattants maintenant qu'ils sont au
pouvoir c'est autre chose que de faire
peur à tout le monde dans les campagnes
avec des kalachnikovs et de poser en
guerrier romantique maintenant il faut
qu'ils s'attachent au pouvoir il faut
qu'il y ait qu'ils arrivent à
trouvez qu'ils sont capables de sinon
les afghans saurait leur vol te
rencontrer et vous êtes optimiste ou
pessimiste quant à l'avenir justement
réservé aux femmes afghanes alors
l'avenir des raids et des femmes
afghanes moi ce que j'ai constaté sur
place à plusieurs reprises c'est que
même je dirais dans les zones j'ai
évoqué les hasards a par exemple qui
sont ceux qui ont ouvert le plus
la fonction publique aux femmes l'armée
aux femmes qui ont donné le droit de
vote aux femmes ce qui était
exceptionnel en afghanistan il ya une
communauté qui est la communauté hazara
cas permis aux femmes de voter donc en
20 ans d'occupation il ya un certain
nombre de femmes donc dans cette
communauté est aussi dans les milieux
urbains à kaboul et dans quelques autres
villes où les femmes ont pu arriver à
comment voilààààà être éduqués comment
avoir des métiers etc ça c'était le sait
le legs des vingt ans d'occupation
américaines maintenant il faut savoir
que dans toute une autre partie est dans
l'immense majorité de l'afghanistan la
condition féminine avant les talibans
elle était aussi un épouvantable qu'elle
l'est aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu' il
n'y a pas eu de réelle progression des
de la condition féminine et on ne peut
pas dire que le gouvernement précédent
le gouvernement les deux gouvernements
précédents que ce fût ce le gouvernement
karzaï où le gouvernement rani et fait
énormément pour améliorer la condition
des femmes en afghanistan donc si vous
voulez avec les talibans oui c'est pire
mais bon là que la condition de la femme
afghane et reste extrêmement précaire la
femme était est absolument négliger
quand vous allez sur les zone talibane
par exemple vous ne voyez pas les femmes
des hommes et les femmes ne vivent pas
entre eux il y a une il ya une
dichotomie total entre ces deux sociétés
et ça c'est la tradition en afghanistan
et ça ça perdure et ça ça n'a pas évolué
voilà merci beaucoup pour cet éclairage
régis le sommier l'emportera arte france